こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん中でゲームはそんな方結構いると思うんですけども
ゲームって全部ロードとかロード中
now loading とか読み込みの時間があるんですよねこれゲームだけじゃ
ないなぁフタにスマホとかがあるんですけどもそれは youtube の動画とか
ジャニから見た後に呼び込んでいる時なんかこういう車月にですねこういう
糞スレそれでそれですそれですこのこのこれくれくれくれくれくれ
これが a 延々に続いたら人はどうなるのでしょうか
この金で第一か終わりが来ると思うんじゃないですかところがこの人は果たしてどう
なってしまうのでしょうか全く想像つかないんですけどまずとりあえずよね今回や作戦
としては触れてものゲーム一緒にやろうって言うんですけども撮影地に見ている映像は
プレステ4じゃなくて僕が勝手にフェスティバル
ブーブーっと今からですねフェスて4のロードぐるぐる画面がめちゃくちゃ a に
続くように編集しますタッキーと録画して
たんでそれを元に作らせていただきますプレステ4金あんまりそのグルーグルーの部分
がなくて今人気のゲームの apx にそのぐるぐるの労働シーンがあったんで x
やり合わせたような感じでプレイして4をやってたらそのロード画面でえいえんに労働
続くって言う特急でございます i まず最初普通に黒い画面から
えっと始まっていっ
でメニューの方いって
エイペックスを選んで起動します
でこの後すねー
これでスパくれる人だったらすぐに来て
次に進めてなるんですけどもこれはもう編集で a にグリルさせるようにします
[音楽]
大北きた一人だ売店させて頂いた完璧完璧です完備タイ今何とか編集でですね
ここ本当に臭しかしないんですよ見てください
[音楽]
だよイェーイ
ロードが止まらないような編集をしております完璧ですちょっと
南鮮耐久なんかわかんでなるべく回しております
[音楽]
ばっちり1時間分作らせていただきました1時間もロードしてるとさすぎて頭くると
思うただ本当にゲームの労働っていつ終わるか分からないというのは恐怖後その忍耐力
鍛えて欲しいんですよね僕と魂斗君二人今回仕掛け人でず僕と彼は本当にロード待っ
てる感じだしときますターゲットは
ロードが au に続いたらどういう反応するので
しょん
準備完了ですというでこちらの画面でプレステ4やっていくんですけども一生売ろうが
続く
apec せ外野から始まりますでは早速ターゲットと仕掛けに選んでいきましょう
友軍主上げろ
いきましょう映ってぼぞカメラがそこにあ
グーッとやっておられるとです
ございました
野党とないなぜ子ですね見たことあるぞと遊ぶ見たことはありますか
[音楽]
しておりましたーーー
奈良の普通に3対3で外がよくましょう
パークはずで待ったと思うんです
たっと気がする
最初のなぜ団体ですとやってみよう普通
ですしています
つきません
[音楽]
感じしません
矢田物漁協のが違うといいますシーズンファイ
続5タイプ fps けれどこれは
いやーそんな時じゃないなぁ二プラン麻薬何かとじゃない水買う
see
[音楽]
のん
he ん
ん
[音楽]
長く
前泊の
うんいいへ
ん
[音楽]
探査こんなことでありますし
はっはっはんじゃないかね
プレッシャーもリアルグレイスてボールを全くやらないですね
こういう者群馬やったです7人で2いければの老後が長すべくが高すぎてグラフィック
とかがああーー処理施設を別人にかかって a というイメージなんですようんそのき
た
がます
また鹿ですね
ます完成
[音楽]
hey
まあ
すーっ
[音楽]
と思う
ああああああ
みんな
いっきして持っていくといいます
いや者もと同じだと思うんです最初だろだから
ん
[音楽]
goo
ティッシュパークですあげる
gaba 9名とやましたね大丈夫そうすればん
多分
ホンダ持つんですが思うん
[音楽]
nokko
やっぱえええええええいやーすごい色
さすがにこんなことあるいやー良いよい広い時すぐございますっ
俺を調べます
んんに当時同人多くの人が節約するとサバ依頼可能性がありサーバエラーに感謝どう
しょうもないので時間を置いてっ最善族しましょう
いと言うと条4 a
[音楽]
見せてつくかこれ一を目指すいってやばい
加味しますついたらせてウキです
[音楽]
だーっのえじゃあ何パンってないと思っいやらしいですねん
んだっはい
[音楽]
ストール金言が生きそうすっともがして1時間以上待ってるんやばよい
ウェバー質問だった精神科不安店2 f
堤字西川今始まったらすぐにして貼りました
[音楽]
me
ツイートクレイ
ええええええ
をエイター
なにこれ
いい
[音楽]
まじかぁー
ん
goo me
えっ
e re だとパパ
see also
tee
ha
see あああああああ
par
tee
hao ドイターやったーっ
vivo
pandan
[音楽]
ん
いつもはんだろみたいなマジで焦ったんですよ
がぁこずみなっていったんでおおっアジャラカーンと踏んだから
ブーブー言っは